running for a congressional seat in the
middle of the summer when there are so
many like top of ticket issues um it's
very grassroots thank you for being here
which is my daughter
tandy oh i love that i started working
at the age of 14
in a bakery uh mopping floors dishing
out danish my name is kelly cooper we're
going to talk a little bit about my
campaign for congress here in arizona my
name is dave giles i'm a candidate for
united states congress out here in
arizona
i would like to talk to you about your
safety and security i'm the strongest
conservative candidate in this race
i support what's in the constitution and
i will not support what's not in it
i'm the only candidate that's served
on the ground overseas in the military
i'm the only candidate that writes over
100 payroll checks every two weeks i'm
the only candidates launch businesses
from scratch whoever wins this primary
will display stamp top concern right now
is the economy the price of gas the
price of groceries we need to talk a lot
about how we're handling the economy how
we're handling energy
most of the people here are struggling
very handily at the loss of income and
the impacts of inflation
the second thing would probably be the
border crisis because we got you know
drugs coming across the border we got to
get to enforce our laws at the border
uh finish the border wall open up the
economy and go through the excel
pipeline again stop the war on
our fossil fuels let's make us energy
independent again i think when i'm
meeting with constituents i'm trying to
do a few things one i want them to get a
sense of who i am you know where i come
from what my background is what makes me
tick i'm glad you could be here so what
part of town are you
in this case coming out of redistricting
there's been so much confusion about
what district am i in who's my
representative like when and you know of
course i don't know if they do this in
every state but in arizona
just to mix things up they renumbered
everything
people think you know it's glamorous in
their staff it's usually you know me and
my campaign manager like schlepping
things into the car
so while i'm waiting for the microphone
i think i can be loud enough for
everybody to hear me
if if i'm going to be representing this
district then i want to be able to stand
up and say that the the needs of
arizona's district 4
come before everything else and i think
it's that simple that's what mega means
to me i believe that congress is and was
designed in the constitution be the
closest to the people it's a two-year
term because they want people that are
going to come back from that district up
to washington and bring the actual needs
of the people and then come back to to
their home areas and go back to work in
the district at the end of the day i'm
asking for their vote because i want to
go to washington and make the country
better for them and their families i
think we're at a point now where we've
had enough chipping away and the people
are beginning to speak louder and that's
why i kind of i think i'm almost certain
that stanton's going to get out